let's say i have the indefinite integral
over
the square root of 3
minus
2 x squared
and of course i have a dx there so right
when i look at that there's no obvious i
guess traditional method of taking this
anti-derivative i don't have the
derivative of this sitting someplace
else in the integral so i can't do
traditional u-substitution but what i
can do is i could i could say well you
know this almost looks like some trig
identities that i'm familiar with so
maybe i can substitute with trig
functions so let's see if i can find a
trig identity that looks similar to this
well our most basic trigonometric
identity this comes from the unit circle
definition is that the sine squared
of theta plus the cosine squared of
theta is equal to one and then if we
subtract cosine squared of theta from
both sides we get
or if we subtract sine squared of theta
from both sides we could do either we
could get cosine
squared of theta is equal to 1 minus
sine
squared of theta we could do either way
but this all of a sudden
this thing right here
starts to look a little bit like this
maybe i can do a little bit of algebraic
manipulation to make this look a lot
like that so the first thing i would
like to have a 1 here at least that's
how my brain works so let's factor out a
3 out of this denominator
so this is the same thing as the
integral
of 1
over
the square root of
let me factor out a 3 out of this
expression 3 times
one minus two thirds
x squared
all i did i did nothing fancy here i
just factored the three out of this
expression that's all i did but the neat
thing now is this expression
looks a lot like that expression in fact
if i substitute if i say that this thing
right here this two-thirds x squared if
i set it equal to sine squared theta i
will be able to use this identity so
let's do that let's set
two-thirds
x squared let's set that equal to
sine squared of theta
sine squared of theta so if we take the
square root of both sides of this
equation i get the square root of two
over the square root of 3
times x
is equal to
the sine
of theta if i want to solve for x what
do i get and well we're going to have to
solve for both x and for theta so let's
do it both ways first let's solve for
theta we could get
if we solve for theta
you get that theta is equal to
the arc sine or the inverse sine
of square root of 2 over square root of
3 x that's if you solve for theta now if
you solve for x you just multiply both
sides of this equation times the inverse
of this and you get
x is equal to divide both sides of the
equation by this or multiply by the
inverse is equal to the square root of 3
over the square root of 2
times
the sine of theta
and we we're going to substitute this
with sine squared of theta but we need
to we can't leave this dx out there we
have to take the integral with respect
to d theta so what's dx with respect to
d theta so
the derivative of x with respect to
theta is equal to
square root of three over square root of
two derivative of this with respect to
theta is just
cosine of theta and if we want to write
this in terms of dx we could just write
that dx
is equal to
square root of 3 over the square root of
cosine
of theta
d theta
now we're ready to substitute so we can
rewrite this expression up here
we can rewrite it i'll do it in this
reddish color i was using that let me do
it in the blue color we can rewrite this
expression up here now it's an
indefinite integral
of dx is on the numerator right i could
instead of writing this 1 times dx i
could have just written a dx up here
that could be a dx just like that you're
just multiplying it times dx so what's
dx dx is this business
i'll do it in yellow dx is this right
here so it's the square root of 3
over the square root of 2
cosine
theta d theta that's what dx was now the
denominator
the denominator of my equation i have
the square root of
the square root of 3
times now it's 1
minus now i said 2 3 x squared is equal
to sine squared of theta
one minus sine squared of theta now how
can i simplify this
well what's one minus sine squared of
theta
that's cosine squared of theta
so this thing right here
is cosine squared of theta so my
indefinite integral becomes
the square root of 3
over the square root of 2
cosine
theta
d theta
all of that over
the square root of
square root of 3
times the cosine squared of theta that
just became cosine squared of theta so
let's just take the square root of this
bottom part so this is going to be equal
to
i'll do an arbitrary change of colors
square root of 3 over the square root of
cosine
of theta d theta
all of that over what's the square root
of this is equal to the square root of 3
times the square root of cosine squared
so times cosine
of theta now this simplifies things a
good bit i have a cosine of theta
divided by cosine of theta
those cancel out just get 1 and then i
have a square root of 3 up here divided
by square root of 3 so those two guys
are going to cancel out so my integral
simplifies nicely to 1
over square root of 2
d theta or even better i could write
this this is just a constant term i
could take it out of my integral i could
it equals 1 over the square root of 2
times
my integral of just d theta and this is
super easy this is equal to 1 over the
square root of 2
times theta
plus c plus some constant i mean you
could say that the integral of this is
theta plus c and then you multiply the
constant times this but it's still going
to be some arbitrary constant i think
you know how to take the anti-derivative
of this but are we done well no we want
to we want to know our indefinite
integral in terms of x so now we have to
reverse substitute so what is theta
we figure that out here theta is equal
to arc sine of square root of 2 over
square root of 3x
so our original indefinite integral
which was all of this
silliness up here now that i
reverse substitute for theta or put x
back in there it's 1
over the square root of 2 times theta
theta
is just this
is just arc sine
arc sine
of
square root of 2 over
square root of 3 x and then i have this
constant out here plus c so this right
here is the anti-derivative
the anti-derivative
of 1 over the square root of 3 minus 2 x
squared so hopefully you found that
helpful i'm going to do a couple more
videos where we go through a bunch of
these examples just so you get familiar
with them